When I think about how entrepreneur
should work with investors that
basically is broken down
between before investment and
after investment,
it's two separate stages.
However, there are some common things
that entrepreneur should always keep in
mind and the first thing to keep in
mind is the across the entire process,
in the entire life cycle is that
the honesty, transparency, and
openness are probably your
best tool as an entrepreneur
to keep a good relationship
with your investor.
At the end of the day the investor
does not sit in the company every day.
And the thing that are really
trivial and really apparent for
you as to use as an entrepreneur are not
that clear to the investor that meet
you every few weeks, or
every month, or every few month.
And so when you do not update or
invest, when you're not open,
when you're not transparent,
it's very easy to lose the trust.
It's very easy to get to the point where
the investor feels that something's been
hidden, that it's not been you know,
it's not been fully shared and
this is really bad and that's bad from
the beginning from when you want to
start creating the relationship all
the way up till you exit of the company.
And you've gotta understand that
the relationship with the investor
is a long term relationship.
The average entrepreneur is going to
either fail within an average
of 24 months,
18 to 24 months, or succeed,
which is going to take an average
of four to five years.
And so, this is a long term journey and
if you're going to be with somebody,
engaged, for four to five years,
more than most relationship in the world
right, if you're going to beat that,
if you're going to be successfully doing
that, you really have to think
how you're building a trust based
relationship which is based not just
on liking each other because over
time you may not necessarily
become great friends.
But you need to maintain
that relationship, so
that the first thing is transparency and
openness.
I think that when you come as an
entrepreneur to an investor, you need to
think what are the thing that
the investors would really want to see.
And what the investors want to see, the
investors want to see your character,
so you need to bring out your
character and who you are.
The next thing that the investors
want to see is that you're serious.
And being serious meaning
treating yourself seriously,
treating the investors seriously,
treating the investors' time seriously,
coming prepared,
answering questions properly.
One of the things I do is that when
somebody sends me a presentation over
e-mail, before I meet
them there is like a very
tenacious process of back and
forth questions that I would send.
It could have come to like you know
40 emails going back and forth.
Because what I want to see is not
necessarily the answers they give me but
I want to see the seriousness
in which they're taking this.
So if I ask them a question,
I want to see that they come
back with a reasonable answer.
And I want to see how long it takes.
I'll give an example, two weeks
ago somebody wrote me an e-mail.
I told them, I would love to see
the market map of this thing.
And they told me, okay,
sure it's going to take us two weeks.
When I got back to them and
said why is it going to take two weeks?
Are you busy with something else,
is there something that I'm missing, and
they said well,
we're doing lots of things.
And then you think to yourself,
if it's going to take them two weeks to
create a market map, that clearly
they should have had before, but
if it's going to take them now two
weeks to update it, to recreate it then
what's going to happen when a customer's
going to tell them I need something now.
And what's going to happen if they're
going to launch something and
consumers are going to basically
tell them by their behavior
that that's not what they want.
Is it also going to take them
two weeks to start moving and so
that was a very short discussion right.
And so through these questions and
answers I learn not necessarily
about the business itself although
a bit of that as well but mostly about
the character of the entrepreneurs and
I'm trying to see whether they're the
kind of people that I want to invest in.
And the people I want to
invest in are these stars.
They're the people that have fire in
their eyes, they love when they do,
they wake up in the morning and
they want to conquer the world.
And the speed in which they're moving
and speed is the most important thing
for an entrepreneur, the speed in which
they're moving is appropriate for
the market challenges that
they're going to tackle.
And people think that speed is only for
internet companies, for app companies,
but it's not true.
If you want to start a medical devices
company, the speed may be different in
terms of, you're not going to
have an app out in three month.
But if you're not going to move fast,
somebody else is
going to eat your lunch.
And so this process is something
that tells me about entrepreneurs.
And I think that entrepreneurs need to
think very carefully about how they
present themselves, and how ready
they come and how fast they can move
in the interaction with the investor,
if they really want to get the money.
And you know on the speed side, my
partner James likes giving what I think
is the best analogy for speed, which I
think entrepreneurs would enjoy, and
that is that when you are playing
chess against a grand master,
then you don't stand a chance, right
there you know there are geniuses, but
even I play pretty average chess,
if you let me do take two moves for
every move of the master,
I'm going to win.
Because that's just the way it is, and
when you're a young company the only
thing you have as your weapons against
the large corporates is your speed.
They have more people, they have more
energy, they have more money, they can
market harder, they can do whatever
they want but they are moving slow.
And so as a startup if you do
not move at least twice as fast
as the large corporates
you're not going to win.
So you know, that's what into
entrepreneurs need to be ready in
general for and that's what I'm looking
for and that's what they need to be able
to present to investors because all the
smart investors more than anything else,
they would look at character and
speed, these are the two things.